Il était une personne économiquement rationnelle.
Il a dit à son amie : "Marions-nous.
Fusionnons nos intérêts."
(Rires)
Oui, il l'a fait.
"Je t'aime vraiment", il disait, "Je t'aime profondément. Je t'aime
plus que n'importe quelle femme que j'ai rencontrées.
Je t'aime plus que Mary, Jane, Susie, Penelope,
Ingrid, Gertrude, Gretel -
j'étais en programme d'échange en Allemagne à ce moment-là" (Rires)
"Je t'aime plus que - "
Ok. Elle quitta la pièce à la moitié de l'énumération
de son amour pour elle.
Après avoir surmonté sa surprise de, vous savez,
d'essuyer un refus, il en conclut qu'il avait échappée belle
d'un mariage avec une personne irrationnelle,
mais il nota, quand même, pour lui-même que la prochaine fois
qu'il ferait sa demande, il ne serait peut-être pas nécessaire d'énumérer
toutes les femmes qu'il avait auditionnées pour le rôle. (Rires)
Mais cela reste vrai. Vous devez étudier les alternatives
afin de trouver votre destiné,
ou avez-vous peur du mot "destiné" ?
Est-ce que le mot "destiné" vous effraie ?
C'est de cela que nous parlons, et si vous ne trouvez pas
la plus haute expression de votre talent, si vous vous arrêtez
à "intéressant", quoique cela puisse signifier,
est-ce que vous savez ce qu'il va arriver à la fin de votre longue vie ?
Vos amis et votre famille se rassembleront au cimetière,
et là, à côté de votre tombe il y aura une pierre tombale,
et sur la pierre tombale il y aura écrit :
"Ici gît un éminent ingénieur qui a inventé le Velcro."
Mais ce que la pierre tombale aurait du dire,
dans une vie alternative,
ce qu'elle aurait du dire si c'était la plus grande expression
de votre talent : "Ici gît le dernier lauréat du Prix Nobel de Physique,
qui formula la Théorie de la Grande Unification
et démontra l'existence pratique de la distorsion." [utilisée par les vaisseaux de Star Trek]
(Rires)
Le Velcro, en effet... (Rires)
L'une de ces réalités est une grande carrière.
L'autre est une carrière manquée.
Mais certains d'entre vous,
en dépit de toutes ces excuses, vous trouverez,
vous trouverez votre passion,
et cependant vous allez échouer.
Vous allez échouer parce que,
parce que vous n'allez pas la suivre,
parce que vous allez inventer une nouvelle excuse,
une nouvelle excuse pour ne pas agir, et cette excuse
je l'ai entendue tellement de fois.
"Oui, je voudrais poursuivre une grande carrière, mais je tiens
aux relations humaines plus qu'aux accomplissements.
Je veux être un bon ami. Je veux être un bon époux.
Je veux être un bon parent et je ne vais pas sacrifier
cela sur l'autel de grands accomplissements."
(Rires)
Qu'est-ce que vous voulez que je dise ?
Vous voulez réellement que je vous dise :
"Honnêtement, je jure que je ne bats pas les enfants" (Rires)
Examinez la vision du monde que vous vous donnez.
Vous êtes un héros peu importe ce que ce que vous faite et moi, en suggérant,
avec beaucoup de délicatesse, que vous pourriez vouloir une grande carrière,
je dois détester les enfants. Je ne déteste pas les enfants. Je ne les bats pas.
Oui, il y avait un petit enfant qui vagabondait dans le bâtiment
quand je suis arrivé et non, je ne l'ai pas battu. (Rires)
Bien sur, j'ai du lui dire que le bâtiment étaient pour les adultes seulement
et de décamper.
Il a marmonné quelque chose à propos de sa mère,
et je lui ai dit qu'elle le retrouverait probablement dehors de toute manière.
La dernière fois que je l'ai vu, il était sur les marches, en train de pleurer. (Rires)
Quelle mauviette ! (Rires)
Mais que voulez-vous ? C'est ce que vous attendiez que je dise.
Vous pensez vraiment que c'est approprié
que vous preniez les enfants
et les utilisiez comme bouclier ?
Vous savez ce qui arrivera un jour,
vous, vous parent idéal, vous ?
Le gamin viendra vous voir un jour et vous dira :
"Je sais ce que je veux être.
Je sais ce que je veux faire dans la vie."
Vous serez si content. C'est la conversation qu'un parent
veut entendre, parce que votre enfant est bon en math,
et vous savez que vous allez aimer ce qui vient après.
Donc votre gamin vous dit: "J'ai décidé,
je veux être magicien.
Je veux faire des tours de magie sur scène."
(Rires)
Et qu'allez-vous dire ?
Vous direz, vous direz
"Euh... c'est risqué, chéri.
Tu pourrais échouer, chéri. On ne gagne pas beaucoup d'argent avec ça, chéri.
Tu sais, enfin je sais pas, chéri,
tu devrais réfléchir à ça encore un peu, chéri,
tu es si bon en math, pourquoi tu ne... "
Et le gamin vous interrompt et dit :
"Mais c'est mon rêve. C'est mon rêve de faire ça"
Et qu'est-ce que vous allez dire ?
Vous savez ce que vous allez dire ?
"Ecoute, chéri. J'avais un rêve autrefois, moi aussi, mais... mais..."
Comment allez-vous finir votre phrase avec votre "mais" ?
"... Mais. J'avais un rêve autrefois, moi aussi, mais j'avais trop peur pour le poursuivre."
Ou est-ce que vous allez lui dire ça ?
"J'avais un rêve autrefois, chéri.
Mais alors tu es né." (Rires)
(Rires) (Applaudissements)
Voulez-vous réellement utiliser votre famille,
voulez-vous réellement regarder votre épouse
et vos enfants et voir vos geôliers ?
Il y a quelque chose que vous auriez pu dire à votre enfant
quand il ou elle vous a dit : "J'ai un rêve."
Vous auriez pu dire, en regardant le gamin en face :
"Vas-y, chéri,
comme je l'ai fait."
Mais vous ne pourrez pas dire cela
parce que vous ne l'avez pas fait. Donc vous ne pourrez pas. (Rires)
Et donc les péchés des parents
seront payés par les pauvres enfants.
Pourquoi allez-vous chercher refuge dans les relations humaines
pour votre excuse de ne pas chercher et poursuivre votre passion ?
Vous savez pourquoi.
Au fond de votre coeur, vous savez pourquoi,
et je suis totalement sérieux.
Vous savez pourquoi vous devenez tout mignons et affectionnés
et que vous vous enveloppez dans les relations humaines.
C'est parce que vous êtes -
Vous savez ce que vous êtes.
Vous êtes apeurés de poursuivre votre passion.
Vous avez peur d'avoir l'air ridicule.
Vous avez peur d'essayer. Vous avez peur d'échouer.
Super ami, super épouse, super parent, super carrière.
Est-ce que ce n'est pas un lot ? Est-ce que ce n'est pas ce que vous êtes ?
Comment pouvez-vous être l'un sans l'autre ?
Mais vous avez peur.
Et c'est pourquoi vous n'aurez pas une grande carrière, sauf si...
"sauf si", l'expression la plus évocatrice de toutes -
sauf si.
Mais l'expression "sauf si" est liée aussi
à cette autre phrase terrifiante
"Si seulement j'avais..."
Si jamais vous avez cette idée coincée dans la tête,
elle vous blessera énormément.
Ce sont les nombreuses raisons
qui font que vous allez échouer
à avoir une grande carrière,
sauf si...
sauf si.
Merci (Applaudissements)